so everyone also knows you as shorty
from indiana jones as well which you've
been in such epic films like right off
the bat at such a young age so do you
remember working with harrison ford or
yeah oh my god it was incredible you
were interested in awesome people right
off the bat yeah well yeah first time
ever right uh yeah he was incredible he
was like one of the most generous
down-to-earth human beings i've ever met
yes and i remember we shot a lot of the
exterior stuff in sri lanka and we all
stayed in this hotel and every day after
we wrapped we would go and hang out at
the swimming pool yeah and when harrison
ford found out that i didn't know how to
swim he says keith come on let me teach
you so to this day i learned how to swim
was because madison ford taught you how
to swim
what is your life
i think you had a swim instructor at the
wires and like i was like wait what
that's crazy yeah yeah i love that that
because it's not always that way for
kids like starting out like i love that
that was such a positive experience
right off the bat that's so cool i got
really lucky i mean who would have
thought right yeah i mean get to work
with steven spielberg george lucas and
harrison ford
right off the bat yeah
[Music]
you